in our age of hyperbole every supreme
court case
is treated as something monumental and
history shaping
occasionally that's actually true though
and that might be this might be one of
those occasions
as cnn reported on monday quote the
supreme court on monday agreed to take
up a key
abortion case next term concerning a
controversial mississippi law that
banned most abortions after 15 weeks
rekindling a potentially major challenge
to roe v wade at the majority
conservative court
mississippi's 15-week abortion ban which
then governor phil bryant a republican
signed into law in 2018
made exceptions only for medical
emergencies or cases in which there is a
quote severe fetal abnormality
but not for instances of rape or incest
a federal judge in mississippi struck
down the law november 2018
and the fifth u.s circuit court of
appeals upheld that ruling in december
2019
after being rescheduled for the court's
consideration and conference over a
dozen times the case
would uh could present a direct
challenge to roe v wade the 1973
landmark supreme court decision
legalizing abortion nato
nationwide prior to viability which can
occur at around 24 weeks of pregnancy
all right now of course viability in
this context refers to the
unborn child's ability to survive
outside the womb
that threshold can be reached at 24
weeks even earlier than 24 weeks in some
cases and it's being lowered
with each passing year as technology
improves because that's really what this
is about
the the viability quote unquote is about
modern technology it's not about the the
child
but really the concept of viability is a
misnomer in truth
no child is truly viable in the sense
they can
survive on their own until many years
after birth
for some people these days they haven't
even reached that point by their i don't
know 30th birthday
the point is that babies outside of the
womb require
constant attention and care from their
parents yeah they can breathe
and that's the sort of thing on their
own can they survive on their own
no and that's that's not a that's that's
you know that's not a small point
because parents
are obligated by law to provide the care
to their children
that their children need and if they
don't provide that care
then they have to find someone else who
will if they fail to meet that
obligation
or certainly if they simply just kill
their child to save themselves the
burden
they'll go to prison and that and that
kicks in
the moment the child is born that child
is born
and is quote unquote viable but still
cannot do anything
on his own cannot survive on his own
needs to be cared for
every second of the day and if those
parents do not provide that care
refuse to and don't find anyone else who
will they go to jail
now there's no reason why we should
force parents to care for their born
children
but not their pre-born children
it's the same person after all and
they're just as much the parents at both
stages
but this is just one of the many
arbitrary distinctions that the
pro-abortion side has made and rested
their leg
their legal case upon as for that legal
case
i must say the pessimist or perhaps just
the realist in me
is quite skeptical that this court with
its current makeup will arrive at any
decision at any decision that overturns
or severely curtails roe
i pray they do obviously but i'm not
gonna
buy the champagne and the confetti
confetti ahead of time
um that's a financial investment that i
think probably won't pay off
the media claims that there are well
what they tell us is that there are six
conservatives on the court
it's a 6-3 super conservative majority
court
in reality there are only what two
with a track record of being a
conservative supreme court justice
perhaps one or two of the three that
trump appointed will be added to that
list eventually but
that remains to be seen there certainly
aren't six
and almost certainly are not five um
you know i i i don't think that the
so-called abortion
that so-called abortion rights really
hang in the balance for that reason
as much as i wish they did but we'll see
we should also stipulate and this
shouldn't need to be explained but
it has to be that overturning roe
would not lead automatically to abortion
being illegal in every state
abortion should be illegal in every
state but that's not what would happen
as a direct
consequence of of roe being overturned
if it ever was
all that would happen is that each state
would be empowered now to make its own
laws on the issue
this is a situation that even a
pro-abortion person if they were honest
and i'm not sure that any such creature
actually exists an honest pro-abortion
person kind of a
uh you know a contradiction
contradiction in terms
but even if if such a person did exist
they should prefer that
because you can be in favor of legal
abortion while still recognizing
that roe was a bad decision the justices
managed to locate a right to abortion
in the constitution even though no such
right is ever mentioned or even hinted
at in the constitution
and they found it within the right to
privacy
which is also not mentioned in the
constitution
so if you're keeping track at home that
is two degrees of removal from the
constitution
the right to abortion is a non-existent
constitutional right
grounded in another non-existent
constitutional right
the justices may have just claimed that
they they may as well just claim they
discovered a secret decoder ring and
found the right
to abortion written in code or written
in invisible ink or something
that would have been somehow more
credible than what they actually claimed
it was just a bad decision on legal
grounds again
no matter how you feel about abortion
it's a bad decision
and that's why roe should be overturned
whether or not it actually will be
we'll see now as far as why abortion
itself should be illegal everywhere for
everyone in all cases
that's simply because unborn humans
are human and abortion is the
intentional and direct destruction
of those humans and it's always wrong to
intentionally and directly destroy
innocent human life
okay that's that's the argument it's
pretty simple unborn and every single
step of this
this is a self-evident this is morally
and logically self-evident this argument
because every single step of it is
clearly true
unborn humans are human
that cannot be denied that's a
scientific fact
abortion directly destroys those humans
kills them again cannot be denied that's
the whole point of the abortion
so if you're going to quibble with any
part of this then i guess what you would
have to quibble with
is the assertion that it's necessarily
wrong
to intentionally and directly destroy
innocent human life
and if you're going to quibble with that
then that has implications far beyond
the womb
i mean i have to ask if you know if it
actually can be okay to directly and
intentionally destroy
innocent human life then um
what other innocent human life can you
destroy
but if you're of the opinion that it's
wrong to intentionally directly destroy
innocent human life and almost everyone
on earth would at least claim to believe
that then there's no way to get around
the fact
that abortion is a moral atrocity okay
so that's that's abortion that's
roe v wade there's another aspect of
this discussion that i think also has to
be brought up
in response to the news about the court
taking up this case we've heard all of
the panic and outrage and seen all of
the performative
hand-wringing that you would expect
we've been told this is an assault on
women's rights in an evasion
of women's privacy and attack on women's
bodily autonomy etc and so forth
the lieutenant governor of illinois
tweeted the typical tribe that we always
see
she said say the word abortion i'm over
these folks who want to legislate my
uterus
we know what's best for our bodies and
our futures and it's our choice
abortion is care like illinois's
reproductive health act
we must fight to protect the right to
safe legal abortion
yes abortion is health care in the same
way that a meat packing plant is a
veterinary clinic but that's not the
point right now the point is
that the the language here the language
that the pro boards continue to use
like joy reid for example on msnbc she
invoked in a segment last night she
invoked the handmaid's tale
which makes me wonder by the way what
the country might look like if leftists
would read some other book besides that
and harry potter
but in any case here's uh here's what
she said about that listen
terrifying prospect eerily reminiscent
of the handmaid's tale
where far right-wing religious
extremists took up arms against america
to carve out their own country out of
ours one where women
and their bodies were under the complete
control of almost
extravagantly corrupt and hypocritical
men of god
quote unquote and what's so scary and
frankly traumatizing about that show
and the book that inspired it is that it
starts off in the very place
that we live in right now where women
have the right to choose what they do
with their bodies
until they don't and then in what seemed
like a blink of an eye
those rights were just gone so
what's the problem here well aside from
the general
inanity and absurdity of these silly
feminists who think that they're being
enslaved if they aren't allowed to
dismember their children
aside from that the problem uh as i feel
i must continue to point out whenever
given the opportunity
is that they're no longer allowed to
make arguments
like this allowed according to their own
rules not mine
women's rights women's health an attack
on women blah blah etcetera
as a feminist on the left you have lost
all of those talking points you
forfeited them you gave them up you
tossed them out the window
that's what you did i mean women aren't
the only ones who can get pregnant
remember
this has nothing to do with women
specifically
uterus who says that only people with
uteruses can get pregnant
are you suggesting that a trans woman
without a uterus somehow
fundamentally lacks one of the essential
qualities of womanhood
i mean you need to sit here right now
and say that no trans woman can
ever get pregnant how dare you you can't
say that because that would be to admit
that there's an essential difference
between a trans woman
and a regular woman and that would be to
admit that trans women
well aren't really women at all because
there's an essential difference between
them and
and and other women
so you can't do that you can't admit
that
see your ideological commitments no
longer permit you to talk about women's
rights at all
there are no women or if there are women
they're not in any way fundamentally
distinguishable from
men we're all stranded out here in the
same
ambiguous haze now does that mean that
you can't still make a pro-abortion
argument no you could still be
pro-abortion at the end of the day
all pro-abortion arguments are bad and
stupid so what does it matter which you
use
but if you're gonna you are gonna have
to recalibrate your whole approach
and i'm gonna have to insist on that for
decades
your strategy rather than intellectually
engaging
with the issue and engaging with the
arguments like the one that i just laid
out the pro-life argument
which is that unborn humans are human
and that abortion intentionally directly
destroys them and intentionally directly
destroying innocent human life is always
wrong
rather than engaging with that your
strategy has been to cast women
as the victims of pro-life efforts
to victimize yourself identity politics
all of that that doesn't work anymore
you can't very well be a victim when you
don't exist
and i'm afraid to say women don't exist
not according to me according to you
so you have to go back to the drawing
board and figure this thing out
because what you're doing right now is
just not working anymore
hate to tell you well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content